thank you how are you I'm all right
actually I'm doing really well how are
you really I love that whenever I speak
to you always ask twice it's been a
difficult few weeks actually to be fair
I'm actually doing quite well uh the
last few days but getting used to
um being given a diagnosis of ADHD it
hasn't been easy I've talked about all
my social uh media and um it's kind of
sad I think at 31 years old kind of look
back on your on your life and wonder
whether things might have been different
or easier or just even understanding
yourself better if you if you know why
you are as you are and um you know life
for me it's kind of I've got to do what
I I'm passionate I live the life that I
want to live but how many people have
been brushed along the Wayside or have
been lost I guess and not made it to
where they want to be
um because we didn't understand them or
try to understand them is actually quite
sad
and how does it impact on your life
um and my life having HD ADHD so I guess
you know for me I I struggle to
um concentrate on things for a long
period of time I think there's a
misconception around uh ADHD that you
can't concentrate I have ability to
really hyper focus on things but I jump
between and actually working in a e it
was brilliant and the part of me thinks
well is that why that I chose that
career because it was working in
operating theater theater wouldn't have
worked but going to a e really does
um I there's lots of challenges but I
think a lot of it is a superpower as
well you know my psychiatrist who
diagnosed me said it for you it is a
superpower because you know you can go
and do a talk at a school then you know
I'm talking to you on Sky News and I'm
going working on my book and things and
that ability to I guess jump between
things is is a real help but it's only
become that way in later life it was
more challenging school for obvious
reasons it's a it's a system that's
built a certain way and if you don't fit
it's very difficult you want to talk
about body image as well and the impact
um that social media can have on that
and other people's views on on what we
look like and who we are yeah well I've
been doing this campaign with Asics and
I'm really proud to actually think it's
the best campaign I've I've ever really
worked on and I'm proud to see a company
taking ownership of this you know over
80 of people survey thousands of people
surveyed over 80 percent said that they
put off exercising because of pressures
around body image so it's actually
preventing people having all the
benefits and the mental health benefits
that we can have because they feel that
pressure so um I did a before and after
picture and which actually post post on
my social media the before was me having
just a photo then I went and did
exercise came back and had the second
photo done people looking thinking
where's the transformation but it's
about what happens in your mind it's not
it's not about the body and you see so
many pictures of people going look I've
lost all this weight and I'm ripped in
this photo all you're doing is putting
pressure on people most of these photos
are unrealistic and a lot of them are
edited anyway let's normalize normal
bodies and that is what this campaign's
about make be proud to exercise and to
move for your own health you know and
that's also view exercise in a different
way exercise can mean going for a walk
just being outside you know for many
people just walking outside their front
door is is a real challenge so celebrate
those little victories and and get
outside it's exactly why I started the
stompcast podcast to encourage people to
walk even 15-20 minutes each day is
great for your body and mind if you want
to go to the gym fantastic but don't see
that as the that's the only way that you
can exercise if you lift weights it
isn't my favorite form of exercise is
walking yeah me too um
how are you different now to when you
were on love Island well the 20 25 weeks
running up to love Island by train two
hours a day uh starved myself
um I didn't see friends or family at all
because I didn't want to have a cup of
coffee because there's calories in that
coffee or eat a meal well that wasn't
controlled and I got myself into real
estate running up to that and I even
though someone might look oh gosh look
the ABS you had on this I wasn't happy I
felt awful you know I'm much happier now
that I I enjoy movement and exercise I
don't worry if I have that coffee and a
donut with my family I go and I enjoy
life much more I'm much more healthy my
body doesn't have I don't have ABS I
have a very normal body I'm proud of my
body Flaws and All
um but I'm much happier for it and I I
have asked lots of people I've talked to
young people about this as well when you
have this shape that you see that you
that you want to get to when you've got
those abs will they make you happy well
and and think about it and I've spoken
to people who are in the shape and
they're pushing even harder they're
going oh I need to now I'm not big
enough I need steroids we've got up to a
million people in the UK that have used
antibiotic steroids for static purposes
so they've risked their heart their
liver their organs their brain to
enhance the way that they look and I
think that's really sad that's so sad
that that person is going to take those
risks to look a certain way when they're
beautiful as they are
um you're one top tip for people for
World mental health Day first of all the
most important thing that I can say is
to practice self-awareness you ask me
how how am I doing how am I really ask
yourself that question if you cannot be
aware of the problem you can't fix it
you have to be aware reach out to people
around you I would say to anyone the
storm always passes you are loved you're
appreciated we love you please don't
give up hope if you're in that dark
space reach out for help Samaritans
there 24 7. call them on 116 123 if
you're an emergency speak to people
there's always hope a better day okay
it's always great to see you thank you
it's lovely to see you thank you very
much indeed one one six one two three
remember that and we will also have it
on our website as well there's always
people there to help you to bear that in
mind you don't have to go through
challenges alone people will always be
there they'll listen just after reach
out and ask them